if there is one genre thought didn't
lock until just recently
it's the mecha genre I don't know why
giant robot smashing each other the
pieces just never really appeal to me
maybe that's just because from my
childhood memories for every moment
giant robots were smashing each other up
maybe twice the environment where people
were just babbling on about politics or
stuff that I didn't really understand
again was [ __ ] about keep in mind though
that at this stage my attention span was
about Shore's the hoax tempo on a bad
day and for I cared about storylines
could have been about sweaty overgrown
men suffering from bad constipation just
as long as else imagine happening every
five minutes one would have been
satisfied isn't that right Dragon Ball Z
but a few years apart now a my attention
span has gone slightly longer so even
though I wouldn't call myself a real
mecha fan since I cannot feel alive for
me again to the Gundam series there's
still many mecha animes that I like a
lot so with that introduction gone let's
talk about my new favorite mecha anime
Code Geass or geese or gay us or hell
with a [ __ ] you pronounce it Code Geass
set in an alternate reality world in
which the British Empire I'm sorry I
mean the Empire of Britannia cuz nobody
saw what they did there have gained
control of about one third of the world
and they've also recently gained control
Japan changing his name to area 11 the
Lucchese a young Brit I mean Britannia
n-- who vows to destroy the Empire
Britannia to make a better board for his
sister Nunnally and also find out who
really murdered his mother the show is
set seven years later and follows a
story of the luge as he leads a
rebellion against the Empire of
Britannia as is all two Eagles zero that
is when he's not busy getting hard and
while playing chess or screaming like a
little girl so to put the whole story in
a nutshell it's Japan versus the British
Empire with giant robots thrown in the
twist in this show is that Lelouch has a
power in his I called Geass a power
which makes anyone who makes eye contact
with him obey his every order and he
uses this to his advantage in many ways
throughout the series from ordering
people to kill themselves to using it
for interrogation to find out the
absolute truth about his mother's death
though it is a shame he doesn't know
that even now scientists have already
invented the perfect troop serum it's
called six pints of B on a double vodka
redbull the cast for this anime is
actual pretty big some of the main
characters include Suzaku Nunnally
fanservice number one fan service number
two fanservice number three minor
fanservice number four five and six and
finally our main protagonist lelouch
lamperouge ie Lelouch VI Britannia ie
grandmasters Kievan tit [ __ ] the second
with Grand Master's Kim's hit fact the
first being of course Light Yagami I
mentioned why because he and Alou share
many similarities both
geniuses and both have supernatural
powers that they used to quote-unquote
to try to take over the world Pinky and
the brain style though as the series
went on a fan that leach was more
likable overall than light since she
could really empathize with him some of
the decisions that he has to make
I need those show quite a lot of
compassion especially when it comes to
his sister unlike light he just turns
out to be more and more of a prick as
the series went on I felt the story as
very well paced since the end of every
episode always left me wanting more and
inherently made this a [ __ ] a dative
anime I just love seeing what planet
luge would come up with next to battle
the Empire since it was very reminiscent
of definite types planning ahead I also
found it amusing how both Ellucian
Sasaki are very different methods of
achieving the same goal both end up
becoming hypocrites and everything they
say and do to achieve that goal so while
the Lucian Suzaku compete to see who can
become the biggest hypocrite in the
universe and everyone else trying to
discover the true identity of zero our
resident fanservice character Karin just
focuses on having too many naked shower
scenes at you now I take that back they
can never be too many naked showers uses
Karin involved yes as you can probably
guess there is some fanservice in this
anime but that's a given really since I
don't think there's a single average
looking girl is bloody anime and I could
have sworn that the skirts of the school
uniform that all wearing get
progressively smaller as the series goes
on I've watched some of the dubbing for
this series and I can say that all in
all I am impressed Johnny Yong Bosch
does a very good job as Lelouch but I
just can't shake this feeling I get when
it hears voice I just sounds exactly the
same as some of his previous voice works
such as in Chico from Bleach and washes
stampede from Trigon with one exception
of course being his role as Renton
Thurston from a record 7 in which I'm
convinced his final voice was the
product of the director have his ball
script and advice during recording but
getting back on topic his portrayal of
Lelouch Agoda Stampede was done
excellently the rest of the class was
also pretty much spot-on overall there
were just some potholes I didn't
understand why did the luge not just use
Geass from Mao straight away instead of
playing a stupid game of life and death
while it's surely not just tell everyone
that zero was illusion the any episodes
instead of being so bloody cryptic about
it
why is Nina still alive at the end of
the series well technically that isn't a
plot hole but it still pissed me off
apart from some minor nitpicks I can't
think of anything so wrong with this
series apart from the fact that ends on
a freaking cliffhanger I clay thank God
there is a second series otherwise it
would have personally flown to Japan
find out whoever decided to cancel the
show and bitch-slap them back to the
Stone Age animation is beautiful and the
storyline has everything you would want
in an anime I would like to give this
anime my first 10 outs heading but this
reviews are the first series and I can't
give a perfect score to a series that
doesn't have a proper ending so for that
reason I give this series a 9 out of 10
No